welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
eight four four to all four riches the
number two doll sitting here in our Los
Angeles studios in person is a man who I
met on the set of billions just a couple
of January's ago is stand-up special I
got this is available right now on
Comedy Central's YouTube page 1.2
million view just hit 1.30 pardon me I
need to hit refresh
I will hit refresh we just hit 1.3
million views on samurai ELLs I got this
full special that will also be released
an audio comedy album yeah of dropping
this Friday and available everywhere
good to see you Sam how were you brought
up to see you man
I'm good I've been on I'm run ragged
from just the road and I'm scared of
coronavirus but I'm good
now are you did you wash your hands
before colors I'm very good about that I
knew that this is the way you would feel
about this Chris because I went back in
our green room didn't even offer his
handshake
no you didn't even do the Howie Mandel
fist pump oh my god did he look and he
was ahead of the curve I remember I did
America's Got Talent back in the day and
I was like a little offended by the fist
bump and I'm like now I'm like that of
course that was the right move so what
you were on America's Got Talent
one of the worst experiences in my life
what do you mean a kidding it's a
reality show like I've done Last Comic
Standing too and that was bad cuz you're
around anxious comedians but America's
Got Talent you're around anxious
everybody right so there'd be like an
anxious magician there'd be like an
anxious guy with a parakeet on his
shoulder and my mom called me she'd
check in on me and she said how are you
I'm freaking out I bad anxiety and she
look we'll read a book and read a book
there's people dancing Mambo number five
next to me they just read a book this is
insane
so it's awful and they just kind of
messed with you a little bit like they
try to make you say like they'd say say
this and say well I'm not gonna say that
and they try to script it right and then
and then before you go on they'd be like
Simon's in a bad mood and I'd be like
yeah me too I've been here 12 hours
Simon
Badman when is he in a good mood that's
the that's the idea is not often I
watched him tear I only made it a couple
rounds on there and I did I did well on
both I made sure I'm like I'm not gonna
let them humiliate me in any way I'm
gonna do well on TV but uh it's it's a
terrible experience I mean anyone who
does reality TV it's like just know
you're in for a horrible I get there at
10:00 a.m. I went on at midnight one of
the night I'm telling you my
one-and-done experiences you know being
a host of The Great Escape
there's a one-and-done season of what
are you talking about it was a mother
seeing McQueen no no it's called the
Great Escape on TNT and on it it was
done by the the husband-and-wife team
that puts the the what's the Amazing
Race that's right Amazing Race on I
should I just flew out of my head Bernie
right so I was the host and you would
have two teams of three and they would
be blindfolded and we'd be in the middle
of like Alcatraz literally one episode
and they'd have to they'd have to escape
Alcatraz with different games throughout
the actual Alcatraz they'd have to get
through and it was wild there was
another one for so American that there's
a game to escape a prison escape a
prison there was another one I'm telling
you a missile silo a missile silo the
boneyard right yeah so yeah so all of
this together right is that I was the
host of this and they wanted me to be
mysterious and that's the last thing I'm
a man on the planet yeah so but it the
days were long they were like literally
20 hours long and these people would
have to wait whatever that's my forced
you to say they'd be like the prizes you
get to know how badly do you want to win
this and I was like I mean you have to
do a residency in Vegas right and they
say I don't want to go to Vegas
well it just you know it certainly there
there are times when you're on the set
of something forever in a day and you
don't mind it and that definitely Samer
al here on the Richard show was the day
on billion stuff that was fun what a day
that was so so you were in the corner
which you were in the corner and so
there's been my friend for ever probably
at least 12 years you know and I met him
in the clubs and I remember like soda
was funny out of the gate you know so we
were doing show we were doing horrible
shows together for years and
I still remember a joke he had it was
the first time I ever saw him I knew he
was like doing I was handing out flyers
for stage time and he was doing the
check spot right just you go on when
people are paying their bill right it's
both are horrible you know so so and we
instantly hit it off he's a great dude
he's a good dude and Dan had a joke I
move the first time I saw him about how
pretentious Whole Foods is and this is
when Whole Foods was even more
pretentious back in the day they've
chilled out a little right now but how
they would they insulted him when he
walked in he said you need a place like
Walmart cuz the greeter yeah you know
like that makes you feel good about
yourself when you walk in like you walk
in and you're like I like that guy I'm
gonna buy a flat-screen he's like that's
remember that Joe be like that's a great
joke you know and he's he was on this
show recent days and he's a die-hard
Niner fans I'm sure yeah look at his he
had a weird like you know he hit his dad
but then he grew up in Colorado so he
said he's a big Nuggets fan loves yoga
Nuggets slash Niners hybrid I know he
kind of gave me great for that so you
were in the corner with your buddy sodor
and I think Miocic right yeah what was
it like hangin with Miocic he was
awesome man
I got to admit I don't know that much
about fighting I'm more of a basketball
guy but he's great I text him cuz I was
in Cleveland recently I tim ferriss and
steep immature
and me the dumbest corner ever I was
like why am I here but yeah I mean it
was so fun it was the most fun shoot
ever it was great cuz Deontay Wilder was
there too and he was just a million we
should look at the picture of him he's
standing a bomb man and Billings is such
a good show I know it's a show well I
actually would watch the show anyway
it's amazing and there's Bob memory
standing right there I got to spend the
whole day with him I gained about 10,000
Instagram followers just for just by
being in within two feet of him that was
amazing samer al here on the Rich Eisen
show do we want to get into the next you
want to um sure I mean so how I've been
a Knicks fan for a long time so how old
are you I was born 86 so my first taste
7 years old was my that was like my
first memory is us losing in the finals
right
I love Starks I love the you lose to the
finals of the againt to the Rockets
right yeah so uh
your seven-year-old you're watching the
low speed of urge a chase in the right
hand corner of the screen and then the
mix rockets in the Madison Square Garden
and the full screen at least oj gave us
hope with that chase you know what I
mean brick 18 shots there 16 - 4 18 star
John Starks I love Starks that hurt you
as a kid he's every kid's favorite
player because he's a gunslinger every
kid loves a guy who's just kind of
streaky with no conscience no conscience
and I loved him but that was so great
about him and Starks was came out of
nowhere anyway 3 guarding Jordan and
Reggie and all the two guards let me
tell you - just since you were 7 years
old I mean I'm 50 so I'm a little bit
older than you
and so I Wow I graduated high school
when this man was born but all that said
I'm trying to do the math in my head but
all that said you're just mixed fans
waiting waiting waiting for somebody
like Ewing and then waiting for Ewing to
be paired with anybody that could take
the pressure off of him and it's
supposed to be Bernard King but Bernard
King blew his knee out just as Ewing was
being drafted which is why they were
drafted so high they were able to draft
so high that and you know maybe a frozen
envelope and the in the David Stern
terrine but by the way great fantasy
team named David Stern's terrine that
that Starks was that guy he finally
became like obviously pairing Oakley
with him was one thing yeah as an
enforcer but you needed someone to put
points on the board and create an
outside game that could take the
pressure off of viewing and that was
that but how many teams one like with a
Gaius Starks his level as a second
option it's right like very funny you
gotta be honest with you almost the Cavs
did with with Junior Smith you know I'm
trying to drum you would LeBron yeah
they'd Kevin Love and Kyrie though no I
I guess that's the other they wanted or
yes they could come close you know I'm
trying to make some sort of comparison
rockets that year I guess or the
comparison because they had maybe like a
rookie Sam Cassell and Robert Horry and
maybe Vernon Maxwell they didn't really
have a guy who was I feel like every
other team had you know bird had a
couple guys magic had a couple guys
Jordan had Pippen I feel like we mix
again had Oakley which is another reason
why I'm I've swore off the Knicks
because of the way Oakley got treated
you know I got I got a crazy Oakley
story please you're first off
at the game you were at the game I was
at the game with my friend Michelle wolf
who's a comic and yeah and she's adopted
the Knicks you know I feel like partly
out of our friendship my other friend
Joe Mackay they're both from
Pennsylvania so they've adopted the
Knicks cuz they moved to New York and
we're good friends so we're at the game
we see it going down and it's it's
insane it's humiliating and I worked for
the garden I had a show on MSG so I had
a show on that network they were like
we're gonna make a comedy show I don't
know if you know there's not the best
home for comedy the MSG Network salted
meat non stop and it was tough because
I'm I'm a die-hard Knicks fan it's
insane for me to just be like oh I get
to interview Starks and and Evander
Holyfield and anyone who comes on the
show this is so cool to me right you
know kid who grew up loving the garden
so it was tough and then Oakley I see
him at the big three you know he's at
the big three showing him an ice cubes
thing and I'm covering it so they pack
an interview like twenty MBA players I
get to interview dr. Jay Iverson all
these grapes for MSG yeah it never made
the show I got all this footage and
they're like we can't this is a great
example of MSG so I I interviewed Walt
Frazier who's the coolest who's cooler
than warfarin he's nobody and I you know
I'm a big fan so I said you know I'm
asking questions to me that are
interesting like you know you used to
share you were roommates with Phil
Jackson on the road that's got to be
pretty weird when you see players living
this luxurious lifestyles you're you
have a roommate like that must make the
bond that much more intense and then
they cut it down and we just asked about
his commentating I'm like this guy lived
the most incredible life and we're just
gonna ask him about broadcasting right
and so the injury's condensed to me like
use a lot of big words that's the
interview basically it you know so you
know so I get to Oak at the big three
and he sees the MSG mic in my hand and
he smacks it out of my hand
do you know painful it is for a kid who
like I was like you were my guy and I
can't like I couldn't even adjust said
hey man I'm in New York I'm like New
York kid I'm a comic like you know I
don't know what to tell you and he kind
of softened a little when he saw that no
and and we talked but he wasn't warm and
then and then I ended up the show ended
up going off the air and I end up doing
this thing for Bleacher Report and it
was an infomercial and I was just me and
Oakley okay right so it's me and oak and
it was supposed to like cut away to
Michael Rapaport and run our tests and
all these so the infomercial it's called
Oaks it was a big production it's called
Oaks in New York Deli and it's premium
New York beef right and then he comes
and I'm like an infomercial and then I'm
doing the infomercial he comes in he
goes with no MSG it was a really funny
sketch and okay like there's a part
where oak smash smacks a deli meat out
of a kid's hands these are no easy
buckets you know dumb stuff like that
but right how to Oaks mouth it's
hilarious and they just ended up not
airing it because they didn't want the
beef with but don't mess gee it's
amazing man and I'll tell you what it's
even if Sam Arale the comedian again
check out his comedy special with 1.3
million other viewers yeah baby I got
this available right now on Comedy
Central's YouTube page stand up calm
samer l so I'll tell you this even if
Oakley had just looked you looked at you
sideways because you had a microphone
cube that had the Madison Network on it
even if he just looked at you sideways
and answered your questions they
wouldn't aired it there's no chance that
if you came back and just said to all
the MSG producers hey guess what I got
Oakley do you think that would have made
John Wallis came on the show by the way
if they edited out your questions of
Clyde right from Clyde Frazier because
they thought it might be to what edgy
edgy risque to ask about what it was
like to do diversity make sure no make
air with that Sam so I had John Wallace
on like two weeks after the thing and
they were like enjoy alright just ask
him whatever just asking about being a
90s Nick every quite ever answer John
Wallace says is right I'll remember what
oak once told me and they couldn't use
anything because every answer was just
while it's like praising the greatness
of Oakley you know Wow Wow everyone
loves oak and so that's I swore off the
Knicks and to hear Spike Lee say what
he's saying right now it's just like
what took you so long for them to issue
a press release calling Spike Lee's
behavior laughable it that's like a
tweet you write when you're angry and
you're a kid you know that when you
write a few and organization is being a
Knicks fan the last 20 years has felt
like finding out there's no Santa every
day it's like every day I'm like how
it's is still happening and then and
then Dolan has beef with Spike this
guy's giving you free branding I know
and he's paying for his tickets none of
those celebrities pay for their tickets
spike pays for his ticket room and and
he's wearing Nick stuff everywhere he
put he puts Nick's in ever scurs talking
about the Knicks yeah but his Oscar and
Samuel Jackson samuel l.jackson like rag
Don on on spikes at Nick fandom because
how badly the Knicks had just recently
lost well it's a sickness and but but he
knew that that it would actually be a
fun way to needle spike because it meant
so much to him he wore his Knicks
phantom on his sleeve when he won an
Oscar yeah all right
this is a called a Dolman wormhole round
here where I where I just I feel the
gravitational force of how what this man
has done to the team and that's why I'm
just all the fans just stay the course
just keep chanting you know sell the
team because here they get thrown out
they get fine that that's gonna stop the
gardening become Guantanamo Bay like
what's going on it's great question he
throw fans out for chanting sell the
team did you throw them out when they
chanted fire Isiah
you know we throw them out when they
yell at the players but then you're
above that for some reason gives you
ownership
it is so here's the thing that I thought
I thought when I saw that first of all
like like that's gonna stop it okay like
we're all gonna live now happily ever
after because Kevin and his team and his
team from security yanked somebody out
for saying that but it's so antithetical
to being what a New Yorker is yeah
Yorker is thick skinned New Yorker is
telling you what you don't want to hear
because you need to hear it New Yorker
is overcoming adversity
yeah that's what it means to be a New
Yorker exactly it's critical is even
though you
point out I'm a Staten Island or not a
real New Yorker I'm talking exam it is
totally antithetical to what it makes in
New York and what we as New Yorkers feel
about about ourselves and about our city
and about our ethos in New Yorkers it is
totally thin-skinned and weak you nailed
it and not to mention he is runed and
escaped like the Knicks I feel we almost
silly talking about the Knicks as much
and how much they mean to me when so
much horror is going on in the world
right but when that horror is going on
the world you need an escape and
basketball is my escape I love
basketball
I love the Knicks and 90s Knicks even
the 99 2000 Knicks Prine and you know
Houston right and LJ and and can be that
was an awesome team
you know like did he has ruined
something that's supposed to be
beautiful and and in New York we were so
hungry the the team is still valued at
4.7 billion which is more than any other
team and we haven't won a chip in 50
years that says that we're hungry and I
can't go to games right now I just can't
go I'll still root for the Knicks and
I'll still watch them on TV I still want
our Jay Baer Odin and you know
mitchell-lamas and these kids to succeed
but I can't go to the building it feels
and I can't root for the Nets ever
I will never root for the net well just
stay tuned to see what durant and and
Kyrie look like and maybe maybe you can
get into that but the good thing for you
Sam Morrell is that your career is doing
so well that you don't have time to go
to Madison Square Garden as you say
you're on the road your YouTube special
is just blowing up right thanks man yeah
it's doing well it's weird it's a weird
feeling because you know I shot my last
two for Comedy Central and then I
shopped this one around it's definitely
my best one and there was just no
interest a lot of people are saying that
the that the landscape is open for a
comedy but it's kind of not there's
really like HBO Netflix and Amazon and
I'm not convinced people were watching
the Amazon specials you know okay so if
you're not on those two I think you're
kind of in trouble and I did my last two
with Comedy Central and they put the
throat I had to fight to get the full
hour on line cuz I said that's how
people watch now they don't watch TV and
they put the flat on line with an ad
every three minutes and I was like dude
who's watching this come on so this one
I took a hit to get their subscription
base and
make sure there's no ads throughout and
well like I said when I knew really in
views man I knew it were traditions I
mean but it's it's great that I
basically said you know what I'll make
my money back on the road and then every
news channel is like don't go out
there's a coronavirus I'm like I'm gonna
plan this poorly you know but it's all
working right now again I got this the
full special 1.3 million views and
Counting on this Comedy Central YouTube
channel you're releasing the comedy
album coming out on Friday available
everywhere sa em em o RR IL period calm
that's it yeah Sam Morril calm Phoenix
Tampa Tempe New York City in Charlotte
North Carolina some other spots for you
the rest of all new material in those
tours Congrats brother thank you thanks
for having me any time come back around
I see I'm just trying to see when you're
back here in law saying I'm back like
every month i day to go out here so i'm
here all the time
look at you man yeah life's good for Sam
it's alright okay we'll have you on is
anytime anytime you're out here please
Thank You Man got it at Sam Moreau on
both Twitter and Instagram